N
DESANTIS, BUT FIRST NEWS WE
WANTED TO GET TO, AN UPDATE ON
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S ARMED
CRACKDOWN ON ITS CRITICS.
EARLIER THIS MONTH, A LONGTIME
FBI AGENT AND SWAT TEAM VETERAN
CALLED STEVE FRIEND CAME FORWARD
TO BLOW THE WHISTLE.
WHAT HE SAID WASK SHOWING.
ACCORDING TO AGENT FRIEND,
BIDEN'S FBI USES HEAVILY-ARMED
SWAT TEAMS TO RAID THE HOMES OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS WHO DARE TO
CRITICIZE THE ADMINISTRATION.
TO BE CLEAR, THESE ARE PEOPLE
WHO POSE NO DANGER TO ANYONE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVEN'T
BEEN CONFUSED, MUCH LESS
CONVICTED, OF A VIOLENT CRIME.
THE POINT IS NOT TO BRING
JUSTICE, BUT TO TERRIFY JOE
BIDEN'S POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
HARD TO BELIEVE IT'S HAPPENING,
BUT IT IS.
LAST YEAR, THE FBI'S
COUNTERTERRORISM DIVISION RAIDED
THE HOME OF A 69-YEAR-OLD RED
CROSS VOLUNTEER.
AN ANONYMOUS SNITCH HAD CLAIMED
THAT HE WAS AT THE CAPITOL ON
JANUARY 6th.
NOT THAT HE DID ANYTHING
VIOLENT, BUT HE WAS THERE.
IT WAS A LIE.
THE FEDS MOVED FORWARD AND
DESTROYED HIS LIFE ANYWAY.
THEY SHOWED UP WITH GUNS, STOLE
HIS ELECTRONIC DEVICES, AND
REFUSED TO RETURN THEM.
THE WHOLE EXPERIENCE WAS SO
TRAUMATIC THAT HE SUFFERED TWO
STROKES.
WELL, ON SEPTEMBER 19th, THE
FBI SUSPENDED AGENT STEVE FRIEND
FOR DARING TO REVEAL WHAT WAS
HAPPENING, THESE ABUSES.
IT'S ILLEGAL, UNDER FEDERAL LAW,
TO PUNISH WHISTLEBLOWERS, BUT
THE FBI DID IT ANYWAY.
THEN FOUR DAYS LATER, WITH
FRIEND OUT OF THE WAY, ON THE
MORNING OF SEPTEMBER 23rd, A
TEAM OF NEARLY 30 FBI AGENTS,
BRISTLES WITH AUTOMATIC WEAPONS,
CAME INTO THE HOME OF ANOTHER
MAN.
HE'S A LEADER IN HIS LOCAL
COMMUNITY.
THEY POINTED WEAPONS IN FRONT OF
THEIR SEVEN CHILDREN.
TO BE HERE, HE'S NOT A
TERRORIST, NEVER BEEN ACCUSED OF
TERRORISM.
HE'S INSTEAD A PRO-LIFER.
HE FOUNDED AN ORGANIZATION
ENCOURAGING MEN TO BE LEADERS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
HERE HE IS DESCRIBING THE
EXPERIENCE HE HAD EARLIER THIS
YEAR, PRAYING OUTSIDE AN
ABORTION CLINIC WITH HIS SON.
>> A WOMAN CAME OUT WHO HAD AN
ABORTION.
WE OFFERED HER POSTABORTION
HEALING.
WE JUST SAID WE'LL PRAY FOR
YOU.
AS WE WERE PRAYING, I BROUGHT MY
SON OVER, I SAID, COME ON, LET'S
KNEEL DO THIS.
WE'LL DO THIS AND LEAVE.
SHE ATTACK US.
I SAID, SON, THIS IS WHAT THE
LORD SAID.
THEY PERSECUTED ME.
THEY'LL PERSECUTE ME.
SHE WAS SPEWING VULGARITY ON TO
HIM AND ME.
THIS IS PART OF THE JOURNEY.
>> Tucker: THAT'S MARK HAUCK.
HE'S A RELIGIOUS MAN.
NOT EVERYONE AGREES WITH HIM,
BUT THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT HE'S A
PEACEFUL, A NONVIOLENT PERSON.
IN OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR, HAUCK
WAS STANDING OUTSIDE ANOTHER
ABORTION CLINIC IN PENNSYLVANIA,
JOINED AGAIN BY HIS 12-YEAR-OLD
SON.
THAT'S WHEN A MAN APPROACHED
HIM, BEGAN HARASSING THE BOY.
TO DEFEND HIS SON, HAUCK
PUNISHED THE EXTREMIST BACK.
THAT WAS IT.
LOCAL POLICE LOOKED INTO IT.
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
LOOKED INTO IT.
NOBODY PRESSED CHARGE AGAINST
MARK HAUCK, BECAUSE IT'S NOT
ASSAULT TO PROTECT YOUR SON FROM
AN EXTREMIST WHO'S ATTACKING
HIM.
BUT THE BIDEN JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
DECIDED TO REVISE THIS VIEW, AND
THEY CHARGED MARK HAUCK WITH A
FEDERAL CRIME, A FELONY,
OBSTRUCTING ABORTION ACCESS.
THERE WAS IN EVIDENCE THAT HE
HAD OBSTRUCTED ABORTION ACCESS,
BUT THAT'S WHAT THEY CHARGED HIM
WITH.
HAUCK LEARNED ABOUT THREE MONTHS
AGO THAT THE DOJ PLANNED TO
CHARGE HIM, AND HE OFFERED TO
TURN HIMSELF IN VOLUNTARILY.
THAT'S WHAT A CIVILIZED COUNTRY
ALLOWS.
THAT WASN'T GOOD ENOUGH FOR
MERRICK GARLAND'S DOJ, THEY
WANTED TO PUNISH HIM, AND
TERRIFY HIS FAMILY, TO SEND A
MESSAGE TO ANYONE THAT WOULD
DARE TO GET IN THE WAY OF
BIDEN'S AGENDA.
AGENTS WERE SENT TO HIS HOME,
AND HE FACES 11 YEARS IN PRISON
FOR PROTECTING H